hurt people hurt
people and so when people are projecting
pain onto you if you can remember this
the rest of your life it's really
difficult too cuz you want to get right
back at them right but when someone's
giving you pain or hurt it's a judgment
on them when someone's treating you that
way and you can almost I've almost
gotten to the point in my life by the
way I'm not immune to this either people
can say bad things to me too I actually
feel sympathy and empathy to think
you've taken time out of your life and
your day to spend that time thinking
about me and saying something negative
about me what kind of pain or how bad do
they must feel about themselves in order
to do that to you or me does that make
sense